hi my name is Dan McDonald I lead the
synthetic geometry team here at Wolfram
and my talk is about our new
functionality coming into version 12.04
mental I'll discuss our main functions
which include geometric scene for
describing coordinate free scenes in
plane geometry random instance for
creating a random drawing of a described
scene and find geometric conjectures for
creating conjectures based on those
drawings also preview some future
functionality for making synthetic
proofs about those scenes
hello champagne okay so my name is Dan
McDonald and I lead the synthetic
geometry team here at Wolfram and I'll
be talking about our project automated
drawings conjectures and proofs in
planar geometry using the Wolfram
language at least the first part of this
is similar to a talk I gave in Portugal
a couple months ago so if you were at
that one you can nap for a little while
okay so just an overview of our project
hopefully you can read that we kind of
have guess four phases of our workflow
the fourth one is not really showing so
our three main functions making it into
version 12 experimental at least our
geometric scene which is a wrapper reuse
for describing symbology symbolically
describing coordinate free scenes in
plane geometry and I'll show you what I
mean by that later random instance which
presumably will become a more general
function but for us we will apply it to
geometric scene to create randomized
instances of those described scenes find
geometric conjectures will use those
randomized instances and the the
concrete coordinates they return to make
conjectures about the original abstract
scene and it's not letting me scroll
down how do I write there it was its
and then finally find geometric proof
will not be in version 12.04 code and
that will be for actually finding human
readable proofs of of theorems described
in our scene language so let's show what
we've got since go back to 100 so we
always start these talks with dailies
theorems because as we say Bailey's
never fail 'yes i used that last year no
one laughed then either so Bailey's
theorem says let a B and C be distinct
points on a circle where the line AC is
a diameter so here this picture we got
off the internet I guess doesn't have a
B and C imagine a here C here and then B
is one of these points here then the
angle ABC is a right angle so if we want
to describe this
we have geometric scene we list the
points you don't have to list them as
strings but this is not a scope
geometric scene does not scope so it's
safe to do it that way circle three will
be a new graphics function I'm not sure
when that will actually be working but
circle through ABC centered at a point
at O and then we have a triangle ABC and
O is the midpoint of a and C so notice
we didn't say anything about the
conclusion and then if we run the code
we get an instance of this same if this
scene this is from random instance and
though this is random instance so if we
run it again we should get something
else if we want multiple say 5
versions it'll take a little longer we
can get a list of different results but
let's go back to one okay and notice
that you know there are multiple ways of
describing the hypotheses of Baileys
theorem so let's try another way so
let's say that trying the circumcenter
of triangle ABC is also the midpoint of
AC so we should be able to get it
drawing here and the drawing looks a
little different but the it still fits
the theorem so in case you're curious
this is not actually a graphics object
we're returning this is it formats as
graphics but the head will still be
geometric seen except we've given
concrete values to the points and those
concrete values are important if we were
on find geometric conjectures because
these uses these kind find geometric
conjectures uses the concrete
coordinates to see if there's anything
interesting to say
about the scene so here we run it we get
geometric assertion this is another new
function that'll work inside geometric
scene of line a B and C B are
perpendicular which is the same thing as
saying that this planar angle which
Charles is introduced in the more
general geometry framework equals 90
degrees so we've got the conclusion and
also if we run it on the second picture
it works there too so it's close that
let's see so here's another example so I
think Charles uses this in his talk if
you were there Pappas is hexagon theorem
notice here we have a we have a random
seating option which is helpful for
talks when you don't trust your software
a lot because here we notice it it puts
out a good picture but I knew it would
because with the random seating option
you get the same thing every time
if I take this away we might see why
plane geometry is like people and that
we can't all be winners see sometimes
you get a degenerate scene so hopefully
if you run it enough times you'll get
something good again
there we go so it's an imperfect science
it doesn't always give what you want and
if we look for the conclusions on this
guy we see that our top conclusion is
geometric assertion of ZYX are collinear
which is this red line here and which in
fact was it was the conclusion of
purposes hexagon theorem so good job
pappas because me this theorem that was
the one Steven did in his talk so I'll
skip ahead to our preview of fine
geometric proof so this is not going to
be available in 12o at least so I just
have some example output down here so
what is the measure of angle zu v in
this diagram I'm going to generate there
we go
and if we run our conjecture code just
for completeness will see that it finds
that V Z is 150 degrees and if we want
an automated proof I don't have code to
actually run on this but at some point
this will be available you'll return a
proof object and then you'll be able to
format it where you'll have facts and
reasoning and at the bottom you should
get what you want so since XC you are on
a line z v is just x u v by another name
which is 150 degrees and
it should follow from these things up
here okay next okay so some other things
we can do so let's look at thins were
heading or theorem so suppose a b c d
and a b-prime c-prime d-prime are two
squares with the common vertex a
something something something and the
conclusion is this quadrilateral qrst
must be a square as well so let's create
a scene description based on those
hypotheses so we've got two polygons
they're squares so we say geometric
assertion regular we have Q s R and T
are these various midpoints and then
this polygon qrst I'm not making any
assertions about it
but we're just going to draw it to see
what it looks like and according to fins
are had a girth theorem this polygon
qrst must be a square so let's run this
and what do we get it is not a square
that looks like a parallel non square
parallelogram so you know if we in fact
try to find conjectures about this being
a square we don't find anything so what
went wrong we need to add the assumption
that the two original squares are both
counterclockwise so this is something
that I think we got this from math world
was not present in this original problem
description so it's something where
later on if you're doing automated
reasoning about theorems like this
Computers don't make assumptions so this
is a tool for seeing if you are making
any implicit assumptions that you're not
aware of so if we actually run it with
this additional assertion that p1 and p2
have the same orientation we see that in
fact we do get a square so finns learn
how to ger who I looked up are both dead
but now they can rest in peace because
their theorem lives on and our
conjecture code does find the conclusion
not yet I believe so
although I was mostly looking over my
talk during that talk yeah okay so
another another application for the the
drawer is in polygon dissections and so
I don't know if pigs in the audience but
he found these so a perfect dissection
of a polygon is a decomposition of the
polygon and to internally disjoint
polygons finite finite number more than
one that are mutually similar but tear
wise in congruence so there's this area
of mathematics where you describe a
dissection and see if it's possible to
actually achieve it so here's one notice
these numbers are just labelings for the
lines not not lengths so we want to give
a dissection of of a triangle into 1 2 3
4 5 6
similar try similar triangles and if we
run this this one can
take a while except if you pick the
right seat it does not and in fact we
get this we get the construction that
took us human so long to come up with up
there and we can do this again with this
dissection here so let's see if ours
looks similar to theirs it does so also
notice that if you name so notice you
can use style around any of your
willy-nilly around any of your your
graphics primitives and if you give it a
name you'll get a tooltip okay so that
was kind of what's going on inside of
geometric scene we found that we needed
some more functionality to kind of fully
be able to fully Express the the breadth
of planar geometry and some of this
functionality is going to be able to
live outside of geometric scene so
triangle construct is one and so these
these are the heads in blue and the
strings if they're here are our
specifications so you know we have some
somewhat obscure things medial triangle
anti medial triangle you can look on so
triangle construct will return something
that you can put directly and Graphix
triangle measurement will return a
scalar value triangle Center is similar
to triangle contract except it it only
works it only returns lists of
coordinates for points
so this this list of strings will be a
subset of this list of strings we just
we have midpoint which doesn't take any
specifications if you're at Charles's
talk
he's implemented planar angle and
polygon angle and we've also implemented
angle bisector and perpendicular
bisectors let's see some of these things
in action right so if we look at a
nine-point circle we'll show you why
it's called a nine-point circle so it's
from these things right so it's it's a
nine-point circle is defined based on a
triangle and so it's Center is one of
our triangle senders and the vast
majority of these functions and their
specifications work on abstract input so
we've got a nine-point center a nine
point radius and that should be enough
to give us a nine-point circle and if it
works on abstract input it should work
on concrete input so for you you're on
this here we see why it's called a
nine-point circle so you've got this
triangle we've got three feet of the
triangle an ortho Center three midpoints
between the orthocenter and the vertices
of the triangle three midpoints of the
triangle and that gives us a total of
nine points that this nine-point circle
happens to go through if we look at
angles and bisectors we can run this
we've got angle bisectors which would be
this guy exterior angle bisectors which
will be this guy at the same vertex
perpendicular bisectors which would be
this
guy here so these bisectors return
infinite lines
I fear Charles's talk you saw the stuff
we can do with angles now so planar
angle so this is a planar angle so this
would be at the point two zero which
would be over here if you don't add
additional specification and it just
gives the angle between 0 and pi but you
can also give the specification for
orientation so clockwise will be the
same thing PI over 4 counter clockwise
will be going the other way
7 PI over 4 we also have polygon angle
where you give it a polygon and you can
specify based on a vertex or an index of
a vertex so this would be this angle
over here 63 and 1/2 degrees about so
that's the interior angle we also can
give the exterior angle which is if you
extend one of these sides out or the
full exterior angle which is if you go
all the way around the outside and then
I got about 30 seconds left before
questions so we'll just do some more
constructions right so here are an
original triangles the one in green and
then the medial triangles on the inside
anti media on the outside we've got the
3x circles of a triangle and here we
notice that one way of defining the
orthocenter of a triangle is the
intersection points of all the altitudes
and finally if you've ever heard of an
Euler line it's the line that goes
through several important points not the
least important of which are the
centroid the orthocenter the
circumcenter and the nine-point center
ok so thanks for listening so the rest
of synthetic geometry team the ones who
are actually here are are Ian and James
Lin Kong and Pete
Bryn's and michael trot are not here
peter is working on the the prover Lin
does the conjecture code also we also
have thanks for our test suite
developers graphics and formatting and
especially Charles and eat I have helped
with that a lot because we're mostly
alpha people kind of fumbling around in
the dark and a mathematical world so
thank you
[Applause]